sinon ça nous rajeunit pas tout ça
joyeux anniversaire à mon pote je te
prie ton gâteau comme thème bien bon bah
merci beaucoup d'être là tu veux du
gâteau et mamie aussi évoluer en plus
j'ai rien mangé depuis trois jours là je
me tape une gastro je vous ai parlé
détails mais quand j'allais aux chiottes
merci nicolas besson en fait vous avez
vu la vidéo sur youtube plus vous
envoyer par mail on a vu ça de vrai je
te les montrer c'est les vacances de
félix et pauline oui ça qu'a fait david
et aux deux seuls ses bienfaits oui elle
est pas mal on prévoir du gâteau et vous
avez lu le commentaire qui était passée
en dessous j'avais vu ça nous c'est quoi
ce que montre cette vidéo c'est de la
merde j'ai perdu trois minutes de ma vie
c'est ce qu'ils disent à peu près pareil
ne donnait pas pensé pâtisserie c'est
tout tout cas visa ce sommaire d'eau et
gonflés en plus il dit même pas qui il
est partout des commentaires abondent
alors c'est n'importe quoi alors
internet fixe ne prend pas pour toi elle
est très très bien ta vidéo suis sûr
qu'ils pensaient pasquini mais je pense
totalement ce que je dis je dois payer
ou pour voir tous ceux petits merdeux là
si je la trappe à des rixes
il n'y a rien de grave du commentaire
comme ça sur internet y en a plein dans
ton frère tu l'as dit aux enfants qui
sont tous ou landon
bon je te prends pas la tête de toute
façon nous le principal c'est qu'on est
aimé la vidéo
donc on célèbre et on mange le gâteau
n'est oui c'est vrai et félix ne te
prends pas la tête
au fil du temps un anniversaire d'accord
donc je fais comme si de rien n'était en
fait voilà c'est pas un petit con qui va
ton péché de fêter son anniversaire
je voulais le commentaire voilà
maintenant le gâteau joue mieux si le
fait que cette vidéo et en privé et que
ceux présents dans cette pièce
occupes voir et commenter la vidéo
thomas pourquoi tu écris des conneries
pareil pour moi je suis plus gélifiée
nous donne tout et tout le monde sait ça
on sait qu'anne s'est retroussée toit où
ces mamans mais on va dire ça
bon c'est toi nicolas pas du tout moi
j'ai trouvé très bien cette vidéo là
faut arrêter
tu crois que j'avais pas te cramer soute
et teaser espèce de ses salles
elle lui ça va ça va ça va j'ai du mal à
me concentrer g force inouïe il doit y
avoir une erreur n'a pas pu laisser un
commentaire comme ça c'est pas notre
genre à s'élancer ce que dit inquiète
comment ce qu'elle est ce genre de
commentaires sur moi je suis pas nous
laisser tranquille un peu ou alors
quelqu'un a laissé son ordinateur allumé
avec d'autres personnes autour
et c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui ait mis
un commentaire sur l'ordinateur de la
personne qui avait laissé les
ordinateurs allumés
ah bah voilà ça c'est ça c'est possible
1 techniquement c'est possible
ben tu vois filou tous explique c'était
pas nous d'accord donc en fait c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui est utilisé votre
ordinateur pour laisser un commentaire
c'est ça voilà non mais faut pas
dramatiser comme ça allait essaye de
passer un bon anniversaire et après on
cherchera qui s'est donc vous n'y êtes
pour rien voilà donc on peut fêter ça au
nom gigaton à les filous pourquoi vous
m'appelez fils ou ridicule mais non non
c'est pas riziculture bien que nous qui
t'avons comme ça donc c'est pas grave
c'est notre petit fils ou petit filou va
crever six loups
bon qui a écrit ces conneries c'est
comme ça donc l'un d'entre vous a fait
ça et voulait m'acheter un faute
jabra vous la famille un jour dit toi
bien la famille c'était génial
oui mais quand on voit la pauvre et jean
pascal mais dans tout le monde et
comment la part d'un mois tu sais pas où
j'ai grandi match je rigolais en faites
pas ce que je peux pas c'est mon
meilleur ami pour jouer et à une chose
pareille c'est pas nikos et surat il
sait pas écrire sans faire de fautes
d'orthographe
voilà et c'est lui qui a ramené le
gâteau d'ailleurs week-end vraiment
content non mais ça va pas qu'est ce
qu'il prend tu dis parfois n'importe
quoi quand et énervé peut-être que j'en
ai vous êtes vraiment tous les malades
ou faire soigner thomas c'est pas moi
c'est toi c'est forcément là je vais
même pas vu ce commentaire donc ça veut
dire que c'est peut être moi mais tu
d'autres j'hallucine où ça marche je
crois pas c'est moi qui ai posté ce
commentaire
j'ai même pas pourquoi
il ya longtemps là-bas aussi posté une
vidéo sur youtube et vous m'avez insulté
hier je passe une journée de merde je
rends plus tu me parles de ta vidéo tout
sourire mais savait pas qu'elle était en
privé je voulais peut-être te rendre
moins heureux pour me sentir mieux
le pire c'est qu'elle est pas si mal ta
vidéo
je me suis jamais sorti au sillage de
toute ma vie je regrette tellement je
suis mort de honte
je suis désolé
mais quelle histoire des fois sous
couvert d'anonymat
on fait des choses qu'on ferait pas dans
la vraie vie terrain mais en partant
c'est bien quand ça se termine à mon
fils où je propose qu'on passe à autre
chose et quand même un anniversaire à
fêter la non qui veut du gâteau à moi et
m'a mis aussi vulgate konan banny l on
veut juste avant une question est ce que
vous savez qui a commenté
ouais t'as trop raison thomas papa non
ça n'a jamais été un langage djeuns